we're learning new details about the
first in a series of investigations into
Boeing's troubled 737 max jet the
aircraft has been grounded for more than
six months after two deadly crashes
killed 346 people Kris Van Cleave spoke
to the new head of the FAA he's at
Reagan National Airport just outside
Washington DC so Kris what did he tell
you
well good morning he certainly has some
unanswered questions this report the
first of many the FAA may have the final
report by the end of the month right now
it is in draft form but sources tell CBS
News this panel of international air
safety regulators will make about 10
recommendations to the FAA including the
need for more transparency better
communication and information sharing
during the approval process for aircraft
it's also expected to call for a new
focus on how pilots interact with the
increasingly complicated automated
systems on new airplanes some of the
recommendations will be aimed at
improving the process when the FAA
delegates approval powers to companies
like Boeing the new FAA Administrator
says he can't yet say whether the max
was properly certified do you have
questions that are unanswered are there
things that you want to know the answer
to
I certainly there are certainly things I
want to know the answer to like what but
well like like aren't were there gaps in
the process and are we properly
resourced you know do we need to to to
go to Congress and ask for the balance
between how much work is delegated and
how much is kept within the FAA Boeing
CEO and its chief engineer for
commercial airlines have been invited to
testify before Congress at the end of
next month Boeing says it is reviewing
the invitation and plans to continue
cooperating with Congress Tony
hope they get this right Chris thank you
very much